other news tonight more violence on the
strip this weekend
metro police respond to a shooting last
night at circus circus
8 news news reporter kirsten drummond is
live in our newsroom now with the latest
on this investigation
kristen sasha the shooting happened
inside the venture dome theme park
around 7 30 last night
police say three people were taken to
the hospital and
are expected to be okay now this is the
latest in a string of violence along the
resort corridor in recent months
and a warning some may find the video
you're about to see graphic
commotion at circus circus
this cell phone video posted on social
media shows several people
in a fight throwing punches inside the
crowded adventure dome
until someone fires a gun three times
and the crowd scrambles for cover it
hurts because
like this should be a family area metro
police say three people were shot and
taken to the hospital
causing concerns now among tourists i
don't feel safe with my kids here
the latest in a rise of strip crime but
metro police continue
trying to address it during operation
persistent pressure
we have increased that tactic to covert
police officers so you don't know who's
standing next to you
they intermingle amongst the crowds
sheriff joe lombardo offering insight
last month with 8 news now
officers efforts seeming to show
progress recently with
less violent crime reported in the
resort corridor
our enforcement model was a huge
omnipresence
working to get it under control as the
countdown begins to new year's eve
a celebration that remains vague
regarding police presence
we're going week to week it's
unfortunate but with in the
days of kovid and the unknowns
associated with kovit
we still don't know what that's going to
look like questioning preparations as
some visitors remain uncertain about
safety
does make me a little bit more cautious
and conscientious about what's going on
metro police arrested the suspected
circus circus shooter
i reached out to the pr team for the
circus circuits property but have not
received a statement yet
sasha